hundreds of people joined a memorial
service for the 19 children and two
teachers gunned down in their classroom
on tuesday alongside the grief there's
anger over the slow response of police
to the shooting and the killer's easy
access to guns the u.s president has
once again spoken forcefully about the
need for stronger laws but as she had
retancy reports victims advocates are
united states of america president biden
appeared at the graduation ceremony at
his alma mater the university of
delaware on saturday he attempted to
frame the school massacre in uvalde
texas as a catalyst for the students to
make a difference
we cannot outlaw tragedy i know
but we can make america safer
we can finally do what we have to do to
pick the lives of the people and of our
children however members of mass
shooting survivors groups are expressing
their skepticism so often change has
been promised each time it hasn't
materialized
nothing has changed actually we are
moving backwards there are more guns out
there
the gun industry has been able to
promote more themselves
make people feel afraid
renewed attention is being paid to the
marketing of guns to young people a
tweet from the manufacturer of the
weapon used in tuesday's attack is
drawing scrutiny a small child is shown
cradling a rifle biblical scripture
above train up a child in the way he
should go and when he is old he will not
depart from it it reads
now the company's website displays a
pop-up window offering its thoughts and
prayers to the bereaved
other companies explicitly market their
weapons to the young
and what we released here is the jr15
it's lighter
this is a version of the assault rifle
the ar-15 but designed for children the
jr15 or junior 15.
20 smaller but operates just like mum
and dad's gun the marketing literature
boasts
in the absence of congressional action
once again there is talk of suing the
gun industry however a law passed in
2005 gives weapons manufacturers and
dealers broad immunity for crimes
committed with the weapons they make or
sell
if the past is any guide we're likely to
see a spike in gun sales as gun
enthusiasts fear that perhaps this time
congress will act in addition the
botched response to this mass shooting
has anecdotally at least convinced some
to buy a gun so that they can protect
their families themselves
shia britancy al jazeera washington